[Music]
well well well what a frickin chapter
whatup guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about chapter 114 of attack on
Titan holy cow this series is moving as
fast as a sum of that lease in series at
the moment and I don't know if I can
handle so much insanity but let's give
it a shot before we get into the video
remember to hit that like button and
subscribe if you want more attack on
Titan content and let me know what you
thought about the chapter in the
comments below I'd love to hear from you
feel free to leave suggestions for
future videos you would like to see as
well now without further ado we are
entering spoiler territory you've been
warned so this chapter has completely
changed everything it has completely
reversed a situation we were left at
last chapter and it has given us more
information about Zeke and his
philosophy and end goal Zeke ever since
we first met the beast Titan has always
been shrouded in mystery and now we got
some much-needed backstory about this
man we finally learn not only what he's
planning but how he came to that
conclusion
so rewind to Zeke's childhood his
parents Grisha and Deena Fritz were even
more horrible to him than I imagined in
a lot of ways this chapter tries to
justify Zeke's behavior by showing us
his difficult childhood but whether it
succeeds in getting us to empathize with
him his viewpoint and his actions is a
whole nother story Zeke was constantly
being told what to do and pressure as a
child everyone told him different things
we know that Grisha was secretly an LD
and restorationist and that he pretended
to be a good self-hating LD and in the
eyes of the Marlins but in reality he
hated Marley and wanted to restore the
glory of aldia he realized that in order
to do this he would need to get Zeke in
the warrior program so he placed a lot
of pressure on his son Zeke who from the
looks of it had no natural talent and
was always lagging behind the other
candidates Grisha told Zeke and I quote
you'll be the one to save us all
obviously this is a huge burden to place
on a little child and we really see in
this chapter that Grisha was a bad
father who never prioritized Zeke's own
feelings while his parents were telling
him one thing
rest of society his grandparents and the
Marlins we're telling him something
completely different he was a child at
this time so let's not underestimate the
psychological toll that being a double
agent would have on him not to mention
the physical toll of very hard training
that warrior candidates had to undergo
as his grandpa also points out at one
point Zeke is feeling lonely his mother
and father are not treating him like a
love child at all but simply as a tool
to accomplish their objectives we see
Zeke lying to his grandfather that his
parents were teaching the same history
Marla is teaching in school that aliens
did horrible things against Marlon's
that they had to atone for Grisha in
fact completely disagrees that LDN did
anything wrong which is a view on the
other extreme Krish at this point views
yamir as infallible and thinks that she
would never allow al Diaz to do anything
wrong or cruel while Marla views
audiences Devils grish abused them more
like innocent angels who have been
horribly wrong
neither version of history is likely the
truth but Zeke is constantly being told
and pressured to believe these
conflicting stories later his grandpa
asks him if he wants to become a warrior
and fight for Marley and although Zeke's
expression clearly shows that it's not
what he wants at this point he says yeah
I want to become a warrior he is doing
something he doesn't want to do
including lying to others all for the
sake of his parents who are terribly
neglecting his own needs and desires
Zeke is eventually put on the spot for
his subpar performance in the warrior
program and he is told that he has no
motivation and that he should leave
however the previous owner of the beast
Titan who will call mr. X for short
takes a liking to Zeke they play
baseball together and bond as will later
learn Zeke fills in for the son that mr.
axe lost and mr. X fills the role of a
proper father figure that Zeke's been
craving for one who will enjoy simply
spending time with him talking and
throwing a ball around this is
emphasized by the placement of panels in
the manga in the top panels we see Z
getting complimented by mr. X and he
lights up we get a nice panel of them
throwing the baseball around this is
directly contrasted to a panel beneath
where Z comes home and his father has no
time for him he wants to talk to his dad
but his dad interrupts him and tells him
that he'll listen to him later
this is a repeating pattern in their
relationship Grisha is always
prioritizing the LD restorationist over
his son it is revealed that for the LD
and restoration is to succeed Zeke has
to become a warrior the owl said that
for him to become the successor of a
Titan he needs to keep his grades up but
he's been lagging behind
so Grisha takes the son and puts all of
the hopes of the LD and restorationist
on his tiny shoulders to make sure he
becomes a warrior they leave him in the
Marlon warrior program full-time thus
any kind of attention he might have been
getting from his parents up to this
point disappears he is left all alone
luckily for him mr. X is there to keep
him from being utterly alone and
depressed they continued to play ball
and talk mr. X reveals that he is not a
conventionally brainwashed warrior he is
a Titan researcher and he thinks it's
ridiculous that there is a dispute and
hatred over Titans rather than
appreciation he doesn't want Zeke to
become a warrior because it would mean
shortening his life and he knows that
Zeke doesn't want to become a warrior he
actually cares about Zeke's life and
feelings unlike Grisha who just wants
him to sacrifice himself for the LD and
cause then one day Zeke overhears the
conversation where the Marlins revealed
that they are close to catching the LD
restorationist then we get a flashback
of one time Zeke tried to talk with his
father who lost the sister because they
went beyond the walls of the internment
Zone without permission Zeke is under so
much pressure that his stomach hurts too
much for him to eat Zeke questions at
the dinner table if to achieve the goal
of the LD and restorationist his parents
are okay with him ending up dead like
aunt Fay and Grisha freaks out he slams
the table and anger and screams at the
young Zeke and tears appear in the
frightened child's eyes he begs his
parents not to do dangerous things
anymore he warns him that they'll be
sent to Paradise Island and be turned
into Titans Grisha will not even
entertain the idea he says that they
must fight so that they can take back
their strong aldea from Marlay and went
back from them all of their rights
Grisha says that it is to save people
like Fay that they need to stand against
Marley Zeke dad mentioned something he
heard from his grandpa suggesting that
it was because Grisha wanted to go
outside of the walls
enacted against the rules of Marlay the
FA was killed by a male officer we have
here two conflicting philosophies one is
that al diem should go about living
their lives enjoy them as much as
possible and hope them our lands will
leave them alone if they follow their
rules this is the philosophy of xik
grandparents that xik seems to be
leaning towards at this point himself
grisha's philosophy which he has tried
to force onto his son is that it is
better to die fighting than live in such
unjust conditions he feels that not
being free is worse than death so he is
willing to do anything including
sacrifice his son in an attempt to get
what he views as justice and freedom for
the LDN people later mr. X finds eek
crying because he knows that the Marlins
will discover the truth behind him and
his parents soon when mr. X finds out
that his parents are restorationist and
that it is only a matter of time before
they are caught you can see that he is
deeply troubled by the news he doesn't
want to lose Zeke who he has come to
view as his own son he doesn't want a
repeat of what happened to his own child
Zeke despite the fact that he thinks he
is going to be turned into a Titan
thanks mr. X for playing catch with him
he says he'll remember that even if he
turns into a Titan it is clear that the
game of catch represents so much more
mr. X has been more of a father to Zeke
than Grisha and realizing how much he's
meant to Zeke makes mr. x's eyes begin
to water he's not able to accept the
fact that his new son will be turned
into a Titan so he tells Zeke to accuse
his parents Zeke says he can't do it
when mr. X says he's been treated
horribly by his parents which is true
enough as we've seen they've been
exposing a seven-year-old and his
grandpa and grandma to a
life-threatening situation against their
will he tells Zeke that they selfishly
expected so much from Zeke selfishly
abandoned him while never really
thinking about him at all so Zeke had to
even be talked into exposing his parents
he was told to do so by one of the few
people who were nice to him in his life
mr. X convinced him that his parents
never loved him and that if he exposed
them he could at least save himself and
his grandparents now the question is can
we really judge Zeke for his actions
first off he was seven years old his
parents never cared about how he fell
he told them to stop they knew he didn't
want to be involved and they still
forced him to take on the burden of the
LDA restorationist after all this he
continued to go along with his parents
wishes risking his life all the while he
was ready to die for them however mr. X
who was more of a father figure to him
than Grisha convinced him that he should
accuse his parents who treated him
horribly not just because they didn't
love him but because he could save
himself and his grandparents otherwise
they would have all died including his
grandparents who were completely opposed
to the actions of his father thus can
you blame Zeke for listening to the
words of mr. X who cared for him like a
father after grish abandon him I don't
think so
if Grisha wanted to sacrifice his own
life for his philosophy that's one thing
but forcing his seven-year-old child to
risk his own life against his will
was wrong Grisha treated his
seven-year-old child as a tool while
largely ignoring him his feelings and
his well-being as the chapter goes on we
see an older Zeke playing catch with mr.
X mr. X's time as the Beast Titan user
is quickly coming to a close yamir's
curse is kicking in nevertheless he
gives us some interesting information
he's discovered about the founding
Titans ability to manipulate memories
he says rather than manipulating
memories the founding Titan power can
change the composition of the bodies of
ldiots he tells a story about when a
disease broke out but the subjects of
yamir were fine because the holder of
the founding Titan changed their
composition so that they would defeat
the disease he says all descendants of
yamir are like one part of the founding
Titans body then Zeek wonders if one
could use this power to ensure that your
mears descendants cannot bear babies
then what we figure out is Zeke's youth
philosophy which is different from both
that of his grandfather and father his
grandfather thought you should make the
most out of life while not rocking the
boat and fighting for better conditions
Grisha felt that the caged and cruel
life Aldean's lived was so bad that he
had to do everything in his power even
if it meant his death and the death of
his loved ones to try and create a
better world for the audience Zeek
however believes that all LD ins who are
born
are fated to suffer and to cause
suffering to other humans
thus he comes to the conclusion that not
being born is preferable to living as an
LD in in this world then mr. X reveals
his own past how he had kept the fact
that he was LD and from his wife how she
found out and then killed herself and
her child mr. X's son who it seems also
like baseball
then mr. X became a warrior because it
was a luxurious way of killing himself
it seems clear that despite the fun he's
had with Zeke mr. X agrees that he would
have been better off not being born the
pain he went through was too strong then
Zeke tells him that he'll inherit the
beast Titan but not for Marley's sake
he'll get the founding Titan taken away
from Marley and he'll try to save the
world
he says he'll free the world from the
fear of titans and Aldean's from their
suffering his belief this whole time was
that the only possible salvation is al
Diaz euthanasia he wants to use the
founding Titans power to kill all ldiots
he thinks that by doing so he is doing
them a favor
he is relieving their suffering which
explains why he was able to kill LD and
soldiers without giving it a second
thought in the past he likely plans to
exterminate the whole Aldean race
including the Titans so that no nation
including Marley and el dia will ever be
able to use them as tools of war again
leave I hate Zeke for killing his
comrades while Zeke believes he saved
Levi's comrades from a cruel world they
view dying in a completely different
light because of their clashing
paradigms then we see Z caused an
explosion and the manga says the
merciful man takes an LD ins life away
in the previous chapter Levi explained
that the Thunder spheres fused was
connected to a wire that's been placed
around Zeke's neck Levi tells him if you
move recklessly it'll detonate from your
abdomen you'll probably end up in two
pieces to say the least
little did Levi know at the time that
Zeke views death as a blessing so that's
where we're at is Zeke really dead does
he have knowledge or reason to believe
that Aaron will find a way to carry out
his plan without him is Levi dead
the plan for Zeke to take out Levi all
along because he would be the biggest
threat to their plan let me know what
you guys think of this huge turn of
events we might have just lost the most
Opie cool and popular character an
attack on titan we finally know what
Zeke's master plan is and it could be
exactly what Aaron wants to do what do
you guys think of Zeke's philosophy what
do you think of Zeke is he a monster is
he at fault or I see the product of his
upbringing I gotta admit I'm personally
disappointed that this was Zeke's plan
all along I consider myself a positive
person an optimist kind of like most
shown in main characters like Austin our
toe and Luffy
however Zeke and likely Aaron seem to be
pessimists they believe that the best
thing for LD ins and the world is the
death of all LD ins I disagree besides
Zeke shouldn't be allowed to make a
decision for all LD ins he's making the
exact same mistake that his father did
but on a larger scale his father made
decisions for him and now Zeke wants to
make decisions for all LD ins because he
thinks it is what is best for them and
the whole world I have huge problems
with this but let me know what you think
about all this madness anyways that's it
for today's video thank you for watching
make sure to warhammer smash that like
button if you enjoyed the video if you
haven't don't forget to subscribe and
ring that magic youtube bell for more a
ot content for extra content you can
follow us on instagram and twitter at
anime uproar where we are posting and
interacting with you guys every day and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]